the oral arguments yesterday in the
dobbs versus jackson women's health
case were incredible
they went on for two hours very few
people listened to the whole thing
though it actually
was incredibly engrossing
mostly for the
the failures of the pro-abortion side
and the pro-abortion justices to make
their case
i listened to every minute of it i've
got the highlights for you here is it
actually started with the pro-life side
making their arguments and the more
conservative judges asking questions but
i want to start with the pro-abortion
side just
to demonstrate
what a thin argument they made mr chief
justice and may it please the court
mississippi's ban on abortion two months
before viability is flatly
unconstitutional under decades of
precedent
mississippi asks the court to dismantle
this precedent and allow states to force
women to remain pregnant and give birth
against their will
the court should refuse to do so for at
least three reasons
first stery decisis presents an
especially high bar here in casey this
court carefully examined and rejected
every possible reason for overruling roe
holding that a woman's right to end a
pregnancy before viability was a rule of
law and a component of liberty it could
not renounce
the question then is not whether rose
should be overturned but whether casey
was egregiously wrong to adhere to roe's
central holding
second casey and roe were correct
for a state to take control of a woman's
body and demand that she go through
pregnancy and childbirth with all the
physical risks and life-altering
consequences that brings is a
fundamental deprivation of her liberty
third eliminating or reducing the right
to abortion will propel women backwards
okay it goes on and it gets even vaguer
and and less grounded to reality did you
notice what was missing in her opening
argument
the constitution
the law itself
she focuses
on two things she focuses on precedent
and story decisis which is just a fancy
term for precedent
and she focuses on liberty in the
abstract
but what about
the constitution what about the laws
where is the so-called right to abortion
where is it in the constitution you're
saying that this new law in mississippi
this pro-life law is unconstitutional
show me where is it she can't she keeps
going back to precedent
the precedence being roe versus wade and
then planned parenthood v casey which
kind of affirmed roe versus way but
actually kind of changed the reasoning
came to the same conclusion which is
that there's this
mythical right to abortion in the
constitution but it kind of used
different reasoning for it so she goes
back to those decisions but she has to
rely on story decisis and precedent
because the decisions were obviously
wrong
the decisions were not based in the
constitution and so she can't point to
the constitution and say here's your
right to abortion she has to point to
the precedent but there have been plenty
of bad decisions in the history of the
united states
dred scott
right there decisions that would that
said that uh black people could never be
citizens
this uh plenty of other a lot of
decisions regarding civil rights were
bad decisions
so in that case would you point to
precedent and say well it's precedent so
black people can never be citizens
because it's precedent it's starting
decisis what do you want to overturn our
whole system no so extremely weak
arguments and then she makes this
argument from lit and it's liberty well
what show me the liberty show me the
actual laws show me the actual rights
and then that final argument you heard
her make she goes it'll send women
backward oh wow really impressive legal
argument lady it's not if we don't do
this if if we if we overrule roe versus
wait it'll be not very progressive uh
okay well
whoopty do who cares make an argument
from the law she can't do it and justice
clarence thomas
probably the most conservative judge on
the court one of the most conservative
judges on the court and the longest
standing member there
he hit her on this point he said hey
lady can you bring it back from all this
generality and actually come back down
to earth
what i'm trying to focus on
is if we
is to lower the level of generality or
at least be a little bit more specific
in the old days we used to say it was a
right to privacy that the court found in
the
due process substantive due process
clause okay
so or in substantive due process
and i'm trying to get you to tell me
what are we relying on now is it privacy
is it autonomy what is it i think it
continues to be liberty and the right
exists whatever level of generality the
court applies
yeah i think it's like freedom man you
know hold on excuse me mr jess just one
second
yeah man it's just kind of like you know
liberty you know and so she refuses to
do what justice thomas asks her to do
namely
cite some provision of the constitution
to justify her legal claims and
i guess
even more incredibly as bad as the
performance was from the pro-abortion
lawyer
the pro-abortion judges
were possibly worse i'm thinking in
particular of sonia sotomayor
who
let was less asking questions than
making an argument herself and it wasn't
a very good one
probably her strongest argument
was to compare babies in the womb
to brain dead people
virtually every state defines
a brain death as death
yet the literature is filled
with episodes of people who are
completely and elderly injured
responding to stimuli
um it there's about 40 percent of dead
people
who if you touch their feet
the foot will recoil
there are spontaneous acts by dead brain
people
so i don't think
that a response
to
uh by a fetus necessarily proves
that there's a sensation of pain
or that there's consciousness
sonia sotomayor calling anybody brain
dead is the clearest example of a pot
and kettle that i've ever seen from the
supreme court when i was in college i
saw sonia sotomayor give a lecture and
my only comment on it i don't even
remember what the lecture was about was
that i and many other people who were in
that room left left the room thinking
huh
not the brightest bulb in the pack that
one and she has a reputation for being
the dumbest judge on the court and she
is the dumbest judge on the court
the point she's making just isn't even
true by the way if you are brain dead
you're not getting better
you are only being kept alive
or even appearing to be kept alive by
machines
if you are a baby in the womb
you are
growing you are going you're going to
become more and more conscious you're
going to become more and more sentient
more and more aware
the the analogy
is
not only imprecise it's absurd
and
and it it shows a ghastly view from the
left of babies
that they that they
think that they're
dead it's it's unscientific
it's immoral
and uh it's uh
not fit for the supreme court sonia
sotomayor then moves on from her silly
brain dead argument brain dead in all
sense of that term to
make a political argument she says if
the supreme court overrules roe versus
wade and planned parenthood v casey how
will it survive the politicization
will this institution
survive the stench
that this creates
in the public perception
that the constitution
and its reading
are just political acts
i i i don't see how it is possible it's
what
casey talked about when it talked about
watershed decisions
some of them brown versus board of
education it mentioned
and this one
have
such
an entrenched
set of expectations in our society this
is what the court decided this is what
we will follow
that the that we won't be able to
survive
if people believe that everything
including new york versus sullivan
i could name any other set of rights
actually the opposite view seems to be
correct
every time the court has has tried to
base its decision on what it thinks will
protect it from accusations of
politicization it appears more
politicized this is one of the biggest
problems with chief justice roberts
roberts
is so concerned with protecting the
institutional integrity of the court
that he often seems to be ruling against
his own judgment the clearest example of
this was obamacare but other decisions
as well
and ironically what that does is makes
us
view the court in a more partisan and
political way because the judges are not
acting on principle or constitutional
text they're acting to try to manage the
passions of the people
so that objection from sotomayor i think
is totally bogus
then she moves on to what was lying
underneath a lot of these arguments
which is their antipathy to
christianity and religion
how is your interest anything but
a religious view
the issue of when life begins
has been hotly debated by philosophers
since the beginning of time
it's still debated in religions
so when you say this is the only right
that takes away from the state
the ability to protect the life
that's a religious view isn't it because
it assumes
that a fetus is life
act
when
you're not drawing you're when do you
suggest we begin that way
your honor
aside from putting it aside from
religion
i i'll try to i think there might be
more than one question and i'll do my
very best justice sotomayor um i think
this court and gonzales pretty clearly
recognize that before viability we are
talking with unborn life with a human
organism and i think the philosophical
questions your honor mentioned all those
reasons that they're hard they've been
debated they're they're they're
important those are all reasons to
return this to the people because the
people should get to debate these hard
issues
how is your view anything different than
a religious view i'm almost doing a
fouchy for sotomayor here i guess
they're both from new york
well i guess it is kind of a religious
view but so is your view your honor
if the question is when does life begin
now just from a purely scientific view
we know life begins at conception all
the qualities that we would describe as
being involved in life are there from
the very moment of conception but if
sonia sotomayor is making some higher
argument that you're not really alive
until you speak until you're conscious
until you feel pain until which creates
all these bioethical questions what if
someone's in a coma are they no longer
alive can you just kill them probably
not
but
even beyond that scientific ignorance
is the and the philosophical and
religious ignorance is even the
ignorance of the role of religion
what sonia sotomayor is saying is that
my religious view this sort of
materialist feminist leftist religious
view that is
totally kosher completely protected by
our political tradition but your
religious view
that human life has worth and we should
protect it that is totally outside the
purview of the constitution how dare you
force your religion on me
but it's all religious you know we say
politics is downstream of culture well
culture's downstream of religion cult
and culture come from the same root word
so obviously these when we talk about
the morality of killing people we're
talking about religion when we talk
about the morality of taxes we're
talking about religion okay you can't
escape that and what these lib justices
are blinded to
is their own religious views which they
consider to be common sense and and
totally accepted by everybody and
they'll they're willing to punish you if
you don't accept their their kooky
religious views justice breyer did the
same thing religion kept popping up
justice breyer is a slightly more
intelligent lib lawyer on the court
and and he kept asking the pro-life side
well hold on i want you to cite secular
people i want you to cite atheists
in your argument
are there secular philosophers and
bioethicists
who take the position
that
the rights of personhood begin
um at conception or at some point other
than viability
um i i believe so i mean i think there's
a wide array i mean of of of people of
kind of all different views and and of
no faith views who would reasonably have
that view your honor it's it's not tied
to a religious view and i don't think
word otherwise this court's
jurisprudence would on this issue would
run right into some of its uh religious
exercise jurisprudence so the pro-life
lawyer there does a good job of
remaining measured and respectful but i
think the real answer to this question
is who cares who cares what some secular
liberal atheist philosopher thinks those
people are idiots they're wrong
it's
it's like saying
excuse me um council can you cite a
radical leftist
who agrees with your view uh no i can't
because i'm a conservative and the
leftist is wrong
hey um
uh council can you cite someone who is
wrong about the fundamental question the
the basic nature of reality can you cite
someone who's completely wrong about
that to to back up your argument uh no i
can't because i try not to
base my arguments on the thoughts of
dummies
by the way by the way this country this
guy america which i know we're supposed
to say is super secular and separation
of church and state or whatever
america is based on the idea
that there are certain unalienable
rights that we are endowed with by our
creator who exists and those rights are
life liberty and the pursuit of
happiness
if that creator whose name is god
does not exist then the premise of the
country
doesn't make any sense
so far from being a secular atheist
country like these
silly people want us to believe we are
not the country is based on religion and
specifically it's premised on
christianity so so justice thomas
thankfully justice thomas comes in and
he tries to bring this back down to
reality he says hold on wait aren't
we we're talking about abortion right is
that can we can we get back to the the
thing about abortion please
general would you
specifically tell me uh
specifically uh
state what the right is is it
specifically abortion
is it uh liberty is it autonomy is it
privacy
the right is grounded in the liberty
component of the 14th amendment justice
thomas but i think that it promotes
interest in autonomy bodily integrity
liberty and equality and i do think that
it is specifically the right to abortion
here the right of a woman to be able to
control without the state forcing her to
continue a pregnancy whether to carry
that baby to term
the state isn't forcing the woman into a
pregnancy
the state isn't forcing the woman to
become a mother the woman already became
a mother at the moment of conception
the question is does the state have the
right to make laws against killing the
baby who already exists and of course
the state has the right to do that of
course we the people have the right to
do that we have plenty of laws against
murder and assault and all sorts of laws
and we absolutely have the right to do
that thomas pr he tries one more time
and then he gives up he says can you
plea i can identify
the second amendment the fourth
amendment but i can't what right are you
talking about
what is confusing is
that we if we were talking about the
second amendment i know exactly what
we're talking about if we're talking
about fourth amendment i know what we're
talking about
because it's written it's there
what specifically is the right here
that we're talking about
well justice thomas i think that the
court in those other contexts with
respect to those other amendments has
had to articulate what the text means
and the bounds of the constitutional
guarantees and it's done so through a
variety of different tests that
implement first amendment rights second
amendment rights fourth amendment rights
so i don't think that there is anything
unprecedented or anomalous about the
right that the court articulated in roe
and casey and the way that it
implemented that right by defining the
scope of the liberty interest by
reference to viability and providing
that that is the moment when the balance
of interest tips and when the state can
act to prohibit a woman from from
getting an abortion based on its
interest in protecting the fetal life at
that point so the right specifically is
abortion
it's the right of a woman prior to
viability to control whether to continue
with a pregnancy yes so justice thomas
says can you cite the right it's
abortion right can you cite it where is
it and her answer is no i'll translate
all that legal
jump jargon try to dance around it no
she can't they had no argument now does
this mean roe will be overruled i'm
cautiously optimistic
but just on the performance of the
lawyers and the judges for that matter
the pro-life side made the best case
that they could have and it's an
extremely strong case the pro-abortion
side
absolutely collapsed hey man i'm glad
you like that clip or lady or whatever
however you identify thank you for
watching that clip you can subscribe by
ringing the bell getting all the
notifications for all the future videos
and if our friends here don't want to
give you the notifications i would
recommend you go to apple podcasts or
spotify or stitcher or google play or
wherever you get your podcasts
and subscribe leave a five star review
we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you